JOSH LIVNI: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to this week's edition
of Maps Shortcuts.
My name's Josh Livni, and this
is our first Maps Shortcuts
after Google I/O 2013.
So for those of you who were
at Google I/O or maybe
watching it around the world on
one of the live streams or
the follow-up videos, I just
want to let you know that we
do have a new refreshed look
and feel for Google Maps.
So if you go to maps.google.com,
maybe you
already have an invitation,
maybe you're already in, or
you can request an invitation
and see what is really an
amazing experience.
And what I want to talk to you
about today is how we're
integrating that into the API
for you guys, the developers,
to sort of get the same look and
feel all of the new Google
Maps into your websites.
So on our Geo Developers Blog,
we have a post outlining a lot
of details which you might
find interesting.
The key here is the code,
which I'll get into in a
second how you set it.
And there's just a one line
piece of code that you can add
to your website.
And what will happen is you get
the look and feel of the
new tiles and the refreshed look
of the new Google Maps on
your API site.
So before I go into the details
there, I also want to
point out a refreshed look and
feel we have for our maps site
on developers.google.com.
So if you go to
developers.google.com/maps,
you'll see our new page.
Check it out.
It's quite nice.
And the first thing I want to
point out is we have a new job
site, so go to the
job site here.
We can see if you're interested
in working here.
We have a lot of open positions
and a lot of super
exciting teams.
Some of them we talked about in
some detail, what the teams
are doing, at Google
I/O. So check out
those YouTube videos.
And the point here is, if you go
through the instructions to
send in a resume packet,
following pretty simple
guidelines here, it'll go
straight to the Maps team, and
we'll take a look.
It's a little bit different than
if you're applying for a
job at Google generally, and
it might go to all of the
potential teams, which
is also great.
But if you're interested in Maps
specifically, check out
this job site.
So the second thing I want to
go into is how do you enable
this visual refresh
on your site?
And if we go to our
documentation here for our
JavaScript API under the
Developer's Guide, go to our
basic concepts.
We've added a new section
at the top
for the visual refresh.
So you can see on the left and
right a slightly different
look and feel between
these maps.
I'll get into the details of
that a little bit more.
The point here is to enable the
visual refresh, all you
need to do is set
google.maps.visualrefresh
equals true at some point in
your JavaScript before you
instantiate and render
the map.
So as long as you set that
parameter to be true, we'll
have all of the map tiles and so
forth with the new look and
feel for your page,
so super easy.
OK, let's get into some of
the details of what the
differences are between the
old and the new feel.
So here's the new look
and feel of my
old hometown of Seattle.
And one thing you'll notice, as
I zoom out, this cool site
that our friends at Ubilabs
put together.
It's really simple, kind of
mouse over, mouse out.
You can see the look and feel
of change as you in and out.
So thanks to the Ubilabs
guys for that.
I'll just give you a
quick example of
some different areas.
If we zoom in, some of the most
obvious things we can see
is the water color changes
slightly, the icons change.
Overall, the colors are just
kind of cleaner, and it's a
more clean look and
feel in general.
Some of the other
details are--
especially for you guys
developing websites, we've
gotten rid of almost
all of the shadows.
So if you bring up an info
window with the new look and
feel, you're not going to see
any shadows below that, and
the code that you have
specifically on the shadows
panel will be ignored.
Some of the other things
are the default
marker is slightly different.
Obviously, we have new fonts
and icons, slightly new
colors, and new controls.
So as I zoom in and out and
you look at the controls,
you'll see some subtle
differences where we matched,
again, the look and feel of the
maps at google.com site.
So a couple other things, just
to note, is if you're using
static maps, so you can
also use the new
visual refresh look.
So here is the standard static
maps, again of Seattle, and if
I just change the URL to add
visual refresh equals true,
I'll go ahead and get
the new maps.
So go ahead and play around
with new look and feel.
We think it's a super
nice UI design.
And again, we have some talks at
Google I/O you can look at
to see in detail some of the
things that went into making
this new tiles.
And the very last thing I just
wanted to mention is that
we'll be changing the look and
feel by default for you guys.
So right now, you have
to manually opt in.
Starting on August 15 when we
put out our next version of
the Maps API, this new look and
feel will be the default
for our experimental branch.
So if you load your JavaScript
with experimental, then we
will be pushing this out
to all of you by
default on August 15.
And then three months later
when we put out the next
version, it will be the default
look and feel for our
default branch.
So mid November, you should
expect if you're using our
default branch, you'll
also get it.
So we definitely recommend you
guys check it out early.
Check out the experimental
branch after August.
Or for now, please go ahead and
play around with it, give
us feedback.
And we look forward to seeing
lots more sites with the new
look and feel.
Thanks a lot, see you
guys in a week.